ich backe fest was ist denn das als
nicht mehr immer noch wie dumm ist das
denn
freu mich verarschen
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen endlich mal wieder zu einer
doppelt so schnell ich habe keine ahnung
jedenfalls ja willkommen zurück bei
trouble ich habe ja lange zeit keine
videos gemacht das war einfach hält der
grund steht gerade um mich herum um ihn
rum sind relativ viele leute die einen
kennen und relativ viele random keller
schwarz relativ viele rennen keller ihr
seht da schon hier relativ viele leute
kennen wollen hier auf allen servern
sogar wenn ich auf die heimspiele
meine erste runde auf chf ihr seht ihr
ip zu die hf in der beschreibung und
zwar dass ein server prinzip und
gespielt und sondert ist schon tutorials
gemacht etc
dort können einfach alle sachen drauf
spielen die so schreibt einer kontrolle
ich wollte einfach mal für klopp
bauteilen darauf habe ich keinen bock
und ich nenne mich um auf urlaub
nun heiße ich urlaubsreif aber ich werde
mich jetzt wieder umbenennen weil jetzt
denke ich bin im crafter
jetzt bin ich es sah das ist so meine
neue taktik jetzt laufe ich wieder
hierhin wir jetzt a-league hd soll es
bringt wie eine kathedrale fahrschule
kräftig bindekräfte hält die titel noch
2 sekunden
ich bin später dass er auch schon mal
ganz gut kisten noch keine aber das boot
das heißt da krieg ich auf jeden fall
die kiste alle die beim boot sind laut
wittmann links zu der kiste aber hier
sind noch zwei andere sonnen kleiner
tipp von mir so ich hab ein schwert und
ich bin trainer und das ist ja schon mal
ganz cool ich denke es wird wieder mehr
probleme bekommen weil ich einfach der
bock auf himmel wieder habe nur ich habe
keinen bock dass ganz viele leute random
kiel und dass ich mich die ganze zeit
umbenennt muss so was alles von craft
ich mag deine mutter freut mich hier
sehr nicht auf den boden
ich hab nix abgaben dkd geschrieben oder
sie vergessen bei hunger games ist das
immer so wenn wir mit dem account
schreibt mit dem man sich verwandelt hat
dann kommt doch trotzdem konkreter 8
also ich brauche erstmal hier nach man
schade
ein dritter punkt das ist auch noch ein
trader ist schon mal ganz cool
so habe ich jetzt übrigens auch so habe
ich mal ein bild erwischt hat ist ja
denn wir waren auch beide trade wird ihr
mich verarschen
mein gott wie dumm kann man sein
publikum wartet der trader bitte ok
entschuldigt sich auch gerade aber oh
mein gott
das regt mich aber gerade auf
na ja ich würde sagen ich irgendwo eine
folge innenraum bis gleich so und hier
sind wir zurück und alle laufen gerade
da hinten hin weil da geb ich gerade
guten tag herr reimann schreibt malerei
man die kommentare wenn ihr sowas doch
boten
ich bin für ich finde alle drei kapitel
in der wurzel hier weil man am besten wo
zwei retter gebe ich gleich einfach an
ich möchte euch natürlich auch besonders
bieten ich weiß gar nicht wie viel
besser habe ich eigentlich noch 178 ja
ok cool
das sind ein paar eine nachricht
bekommen
api komitee trifft naja so es geht los
direkt am haus gespannt aber allen offen
ins haus und ich muss in welche kisten
kriegen hahn geht wie kisten
ich muss doch eine kiste drin sein zwei
kisten ja ich brauche ein richtiges
schwert ich brauche ein richtiges schwer
die poren richtige schwer gesperrt das
kann hier gar nichts aussetzen linie uns
in der herde kiste nein
ich brauche schwer halt hilfe wirklich
schwert relativ bringt uns habe ich hier
noch einen bogen und das war blöd dass
ich schon zweiter angegeben habe weil
jetzt bin ich trainer und jetzt kann ich
auch nichts mehr ändern und blau und
blog
es hat doch gerade bei mir alles in dem
spiel zwar bei 60 fps aber ich merke
dass es wickelt schon brauchen schwert
bist wirklich ein schwert ach ich finde
einfach nix es blöd rum ist kaká bin ich
wollte ihn angreifen aber nichts
dies bot das lava das ist natürlich
nicht gut so der es erst mal down sollte
es auch dauern und jetzt hat mich wieder
ein später getötet das ist ja cool
da steht ein später neben mir ich hörte
den inneren der trader tötet mich wo
zweimal bisher von trader gehört
natürlich sehr geil
na gut ich würde sagen 'ich packe noch
darum hinten dran und hoffe dass es dann
besser wird aber das wird dann noch
wirklich die letzte runde die ich im
park und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal also witz in der nächsten
runde so back in the game jahr nämlich
wieder welche ganze sache kann ich den
broten nach der debatte immer noch
gucken leicht an boden weil ich vom
server geschickt verbinden ist ja cool
ich auswandern draußen high tech nik sei
es wichtig jetzt sehen wieder alle
kräfte hey hey wie lange ich noch eine
16 ok roth 11 plate one man ich hasse
diese leute die einen verraten war monat
1 größer vollidiot so da muss ich mich
verkleiden nic
ratlos hd man geht weg wie die mich alle
auf regen und können wenn jetzt einer
wieder rein schreibkräfte red nose hd
krämer die krise okay was machst du ein
neues wann machst du ein neues projekt
ein neues projekt navi war letzte runde
als ekd modelle movano ist einmal der
größte panels gibt den verrät mich schon
die ganze zeit schon vollauf zu und
genau wegen solchen sachen hast dich
problem weil wir dann einfach leute an
kommunalen verraten wenn man sich
verkleidet weil man wird schon bald
finden solchen spaß dieses video wollen
das regt mich ja richtig auf deswegen
kam nämlich auch so lange kennt robben
mein bild naja jetzt geht's los
das ist eine map wo man immer kisten
bekommt deswegen nehme ich hier sofort
schon trader poß ich bin auch trader
sind leute hinter mir
nein das heißt brauche ich gar nicht
beeilen ich kriege die gäste auf jeden
fall in die kiste die da unten steht
auch sonderlich erstmal lotterie und da
habe ich erst mal ein paar sachen auf
jeden fall schon mal das auch schon mal
ganz gut muss in die kiste hier waren
aber die drei oder wenn dann stein
späteren distanz schon mal cool legal
so wird schnell runter weil wenn man
während dieser zeit darunter fällt als
braucht man direkt wieder hier das ist
ganz cool ich war dem boden es ist auch
sehr cool
hallo ich berge fest das ist das als
nicht mehr immer noch wie dumm ist das
denn wohl nicht verarschen
ich kann nur hüpfen hüpfen vorankommen
oder was wenn ich jetzt laufen die dabei
ich fest von ihnen geschlagen weil ich
wie hohl ist das denn bitte ich kann nur
mit nur mit hüpfen voran wie dumm ich
werde von ihr buche schlagen
ich hasse biedermann will ich hasse das
einfach das ist bitter du bist das
das akzeptiere ich echt nicht was was
soll die scheiße jetzt mal ich mach da
einfach im boden berühren die komplette
zeit und fällt von ihnen wo von
unsichtbarer leuten getötet hey super
klasse naja ich hoffe trotzdem hat es
gefallen endlich mal wieder super tolle
trouble in weinberg und das macht mir
gerade richtig spaß
wo ich gerade wieder bock auf doppel wer
hat versagt es mir einfach komplett
alles na ja wir sind beim nächsten mal